gisele bundchen addresses her marriage
to tom brady amid rumors of relationship
trouble between the two you know she
really committed so much of her time to
make sure everything was so stable at
home so i could go live my dream the
models echoing just that in elle's
october issue opening up about her home
life as a wife and mother and how proud
she is for putting her family first
quote i moved to boston and i focused on
creating a cocoon and a loving
environment for my children to grow up
in and to be there supporting him and
his dreams seeing my children succeed
and become the beautiful little humans
that they are seeing him succeed and
being fulfilled in his career it makes
me happy at this point in my life i feel
like i've done a good job on that she's
amazing at her job she's one of the she
is the goat
and she's an amazing
model mother
environmentalist
director producer
of course tom spent 20 seasons as the qb
for the new england patriots before
making the jump over to the tampa bay
buccaneers he announced in february his
retirement from the nfl only to
unretired less than two months later
did you just need a vacation is that
what brought you back you took a little
time off and you set them back there was
a little more than that
uh but at the same time
um i took some time away which is always
important it's tough to make a decision
right at the end of the season and it's
not something you just can decide i
needed time and i just figured i'm going
to go at it again and see what we can
accomplish
earlier this month reports surfaced
claiming giselle was thrilled about tom
taking a step back from football but she
was disappointed when he decided to
return then rumors swirled of trouble in
paradise after tom took an 11-day break
from training camp citing personal
reasons
it's all personal you know everyone's
got different situations they're dealing
with so we all have really unique
challenges to our life but what about
giselle's portrayal in the media and
those reports that she's desperate for
tom to retire once and for all well she
calls the whole thing pretty sexist
quote i think this is the system we've
been living in that's what society has
accepted and what society hasn't
accepted as she puts it giselle just
wants her hubby to be happy
obviously i have my concerns this is a
very violent sport and i have my
children and i would like him to be more
present i have definitely had those
conversations with him over and over
again but ultimately i feel that
everybody has to make a decision that
works for them he needs to follow his
joy too i want to try to spend my time
with when i'm focused on my job my job
when i'm focused with my family my
family so
all those things are trying to get
better and better at try to work at it
every day i feel like i'm so driven to
succeed in football and that's taken me
away from other important priorities
which are my kids my wife and she's
really held it down for our family and
after holding down the fort giselle's
looking forward to making space for her
own dreams i'm giselle you know the mom
of two says she has a huge list of
things she wants to do and at 42 she
feels more connected with her purpose
than ever i feel very fulfilled in that
way as a mother and as a wife and now
it's going to be my turn it's not like
i'm going to be in the valley forever
[Music]